dudes that were trying to kill it didn't
use words like empathy and gratitude 70
years ago like like just like seeing
like sleeved up like rad dudes roll up
to me like you know kindness dawg okay
it's just
[Music]
[Music]
the context what's the framework help me
understand how because I never know
what's going on in my life there's gonna
be a lot of small business okay and then
a ton of hungry soon to be if not
already entrepreneurs yeah fresh LLC
[ __ ] like that yep and how many people
about we're joining oh yeah we're gonna
have him between do we've been gun and
dog clearly like we've been gonna man
I'm telling you bro it all started with
just I had zero dollars and I was like
oh [ __ ] walking backwards yeah bro we
had to make it happen this is all based
on a belief where I knew Jimmy the bet
yeah my city leader Gary be here telling
you doc Wow yes we're together with it I
don't see nobody in my lane is crying go
get it like oh please dummy wasting my
time with their business who you kiddin
man yeah yeah
yeah oh yes we're together down with it
I don't see nobody in my lane is crying
go get it
like wow ain't good enough to build an
actual business that lets you live off
of it you have to work your [ __ ] face
off to work your face off it'd be nice
if you liked it if you like hated it
because you thought you thought it was
gonna get you the money you've already
lost and so to me it's about what
process will you love if you're lucky
like me that your process that you love
is also something that will help you
make money that's why you you know have
it but like if my children or for
example people don't know me like if I
was just super artistic and didn't have
entrepreneurial DNA I would have been
super pumped and I mean this I want
everybody really do this nice and slow
I would have been super pumped making
sixty eight thousand dollars a year
making wood carvings because I just
can't wrap around any process that looks
like I do something that doesn't make me
happy in a world where working takes up
more than half your life if you do if
you look at how much you'll work in your
life and how much you sleep I just I
can't wrap my head around it so anyway I
think the best business is something you
actually like it's like a relationship
like it'd be nice if you like the person
we got 15 minutes all right and then we
got to get you all to the front row so
we can let's stop let's stop empty in
this gas tank keep it going
there's so much normal
dudes that were trying to kill it didn't
use words like empathy and gratitude
seven years ago like seeing like sleeved
up like rad dudes roll up to me like yo
kindness dawg honestly I genuinely
believe my great legacy potentially
maybe that I made emotionally
intelligent soft skills alpha you know
you'll never believe this is a super
interesting to me the fact that pink was
a boys color and blue was a girl's color
back in the day is kind of how I think
about gratitude empathy kindness I'm
like I'm gonna trick these young [ __ ]
dogs into like thinking this [ __ ] is
cool and then one day in 50 years people
gonna be like the alpha male traits are
like gratitude and kindness and if I
could pull that off then it's like I'm
super fired up to be here thank you so
much for having me so there's several
different things running through my mind
but let me let me start with this
because I want to get a sense for the
audience how many people here are
entrepreneurs raise your hand very nice
thank you but a bit in a working in a
small business very nice
corporate jobs great everyone's like man
[ __ ] awesome that's what I needed
okay let so looking at the hands here's
where I want to go this evening I think
the biggest thing that is on my mind as
I stand here tonight and I appreciate
the wonderful welcome is I including
myself and [ __ ] I spend every minute
trying to understand all of this I think
that everybody in here is under
estimating how special this era is we
put the past on a pedestal we demonize
the current and the future the thing
that's most fascinating to me and the
thing that I want to talk to you about
is that this like doing the right thing
and gratitude and honor and all this
propaganda that I push is actually more
valuable than ever because let me tell
you what the Internet's gonna do the
internet is
to expose all of us I had this woman
yelling at me friends over dinner about
like how this internet thing is scary
and it sucks and this and that and she's
an incredible activists for all women's
rights and all this other thing I'm like
you do understand that your media that
you're putting on a pedestal the New
York Times and NBC is the reason all
this bad stuff was able to happen when
five or six old white guys control the
media a lot of stuff doesn't hit
daylight when we control the media it
gets a lot harder thank you guys thanks
for coming thank you thank you bye you
know you come from a super high you know
that kind of love the audience was super
in it you know sometimes you just have
the audience like at your [ __ ]
fingertips you can just it's like a
yo-yo you can do anything with it that
audience and I were speaking the same
language and you know I go through
rhythms and oh we don't need to we don't
need to go here sir no yeah you know
where we're going yeah
yep thank you and so I'm I'm feeling
great I thought it went really really
well you know so you're coming down from
a high you know coming down from behind
some level it's all improv man if you
notice like the way I start with keno
it's like super happy to be here some
rabbit you can see my name
my head's racing so what I want to talk
about like literally at that point I'm
like I'm Georgia pretension humility
like it could go absolutely anywhere
yeah I just I'm so naturally gifted and
frequently and improv I have so much to
say
you know what it is you're starting to
learn this it's cuz I'm doing all day
I'm doing all week I'm doing there's so
much going on
cool isn't it
it's crazy
[Music]